joining me now is Molly Hemingway Fox
News contributor and editor-in chief of
the Federalist and Tommy lren host of
Tommy L and is fearless on outkick.com
all right Molly you know Biden ran on
lifting the country but isn't that the
opposite of what he's doing here yeah he
wants to lean into this sort of
hate-filled message but I wonder if
that's not a great idea for him in part
because of how he has run his presidency
it's not just that foreign policy
problems and economic problems and no
border and rampant crime it's also that
he himself is doing a lot to attack the
Republic he's trying to imprison his top
political opponent he other Democrats
are working to steal that family
business of Donald Trump they're working
to you know on trumped up charges
they've censored tens of millions of
Americans and so when Americans think
about what's dark and not healthy and
not a good look for America they
probably are thinking more about these
Democrat policies towards censor ship
and um violation of people's speech
rights attempts to imprison political
opponents and then they're not happy
with the other policies as well and you
know Tommy the truth is that Joe Biden
has lost in the latest polls almost 24
points among black voters uh he is
behind uh in terms of Hispanic voters
Trump beating him there as well Trump
beating him with a youth vote and that
is with the Biden having the benefit of
abortion and climate change I mean Joe
Biden doesn't have a story to tell about
himself does
he he certainly doesn't you know a few
months back the administration tried the
whole Biden nomics approach they tried
that catchphrase uh for those that have
watched Mean Girls they tried to make
fetch happen and fetch did not happen so
they decided to bury biomics along with
the rest of the country and our economic
Prosperity so now they have to go back
to their old trick which is bringing up
Charlottesville bringing up January 6th
bringing up Donald Trump he's bringing
back the dark Brandon speech with the
red lights behind him because that
really is all that works is to talk
about Mega Republicans but this is a man
also who ran on being the unifier and
chief in his inauguration talked about
unifying the country but once again all
he's doing is vilifying half of the
country calling us Mega Republicans in a
derogatory way saying that we are
deplorable we are insurrectionist we are
racist we are xenophobic taking a page
out of the Hillary Clinton Playbook that
didn't work for her either that's all
that he has and I love that that line
about him running against himself and
losing so that's why they're pivoting
now back to the whole dark Brandon
approach making the rest of the country
feel like they're surrounded by a bunch
of racists because that's all that they
have you mentioned judge they have the
abortion issue they have climate change
they have racism but that's it when
you've got an open border and you've got
a plummeting economy and a
commander-in-chief who quite frankly
doesn't know where he's at most of the
time this is all you have to go with all
right and Molly I want to go back to
what Jackie said a few moments ago uh
some of the younger Aids on Biden's
reelection campaign have been grimly
joking the campaign is getting ready to
go full on Hitler Molly is this
surprising no it is something we've seen
from President Biden since he first ran
for office in 2020 he really does lean
into this hate-filled rhetoric where he
attacks half the country where he where
he talks in such dark terms about the
people that he purports to lead but
again it doesn't work in part because
the Democrat Party is the one that is
right now associated with limits on
people's speech expression where they
are going after they're literally trying
to imprison a very popular political
opponent and remove him from the ballot
so if you want comparisons to dictators
or authoritarians you see it all with
the Biden Administration and you don't
just have it where he's making this
claim against someone you also have the
experience of what the Trump
Administration was like where someone
was in charge of the Department of
Justice and didn't use it to go after
his political enemies and didn't use it
to take Joe Biden off The Ballot or
other Democrats off the ballot and so
when you see that side by-side
comparison and one is really working to
restrict speech expression and free
elections it doesn't work to have some
of this outlandish rhetoric that is
being used by the Biden Administration
and you know Tommy finally I want you to
take a listen to Nancy Pelosi and then I
want your
response the president has said we have
more work to be done and let's have a
debate on who's there for the American
people I am very excited about what
Biden has done we were a part of that
but more importantly what he will do you
think American people are feeling that
Tommy uh no there're certainly not but
I'm glad that Nancy Pelosi brought up a
debate I hope that that means that Joe
Biden is open to debating Donald Trump I
think he's certainly going to try to
skirt that as much as he wants to go on
these hatefield campaigns to talk about
racism I think that he will still spend
the majority of his campaign in the
basement I hope to see him out there
with Donald Trump and let's talk about
some of these policy positions let's
talk about the economy let's talk about
the open border and the fact that our
cities are being flooded with illegal
immigrants I look forward to that so I'm
glad that Nancy Peli is teeing that up
for the debate and I hope that Joe Biden
will follow through on that promise yeah
I wouldn't hold my breath on that one
Molly and Tommy thanks so much for
joining us tonight hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else